according to gives moto Australia
there's one song Ozzy's play on Spotify
the most during sex let's take a listen
to the greatest song to get you in the
mood for going down I'm done yeah
that'll make it that'll make your force
awaken of course digger and Dan in the
mobile mode Cantina band otherwise known
as the top song on the sexy times
playlist which may sound weird to you
but in Star Wars Canon is 100% true this
genre of music is called jizz whale
absolutely true j ZZ w ail coaches whale
yeah oh they didn't hear that I said I
saw that coming
[Applause]
kids wailing is also a term for crying
while you masturbate to be Arthur in the
Star Wars Holiday Special
they're comedians what is a Star Wars
sex move that you would do to the
cantina band saw hey mate one in the
pink
two in the pink yeah oh okay
job in the butt yes good Anna it's a
crap yeah boys very good well done